olá a todos pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dark seja muito bem-vindo jornais eu
vivi e hoje trago jec serrinha na cidade
aos pessoal eu tô com medo eu juro que
eu tô com medo mas o mesmo já não tava
guia vamos mais nos carros londrina mas
daí steel não esquecendo que foi
recomendado por vocês por isso se for
uma bota a culpa é nossa é 321 play obra
possível que os menores saindo do
figueiral ti e sua linda deputter fã
olha eu fiz então fui lá os mantinham
deficiência que será que ela vai morrer
num como assim o ato na casa do r potter
olha aí à porta é mágica portas e
maçanetas muito bem embora lá pessoal
agora a sério agora a sério não quer
estamos dentro de uma casa tururi fica
muito mal assombrada nos do moniz o foi
de 8 bits ou fitch ok eu vou lhes tempo
31 contra 8 é [ __ ] imagens que revelam a
verdade das londrina é sua trilha tem um
segredo e nós temos que encontrar os
credores londrina faz todo sentido este
jogo vamos lá então óculos são jacumã
como é de porta esporte em todo o lado
até agora vamos abrir esta porta e meu
deus não ter uma se não está tudo vazio
como assim aposta forte o que é isto meu
ver uma cama sem colchão pouco é tanto
uma pizza uma pista 18 já tem uma pista
o que irã várias microsoft é preciso pôr
de pedra quem não é só investigar os
armários já não era um bônus família
pistola
eu posso tentação das pistolas de água
em bairros por extermínio
o trem-bala de que vamos lá continuar a
explorar a casa que tem casas mãe também
sabe quando vocês vão deserto o
encontrou aquela areia morta tipo china
x fissuras
eles não terão essa textura aqui na casa
toda como assim sou um arquiteto do sara
olham to phone amarelo é o sabia eu sei
é algo que eu falo sem fio já pensava em
salvar o sistema de tecnologia pessoal
este jogo é a tecnologia extrema o
banheiro vários tipos em nada tudo vazio
já um pouco turva precipitou eu estou
mandando
paulo chico no preço em londrina quase
nenhuma
o canalha e jotapeg o bom ongs não é um
tipo de esquerda regista um shopping
sequer falei para não derrubar o cristo
mas xavi meu deus peraí pessoal vou
abrir a porta já encontrei um pneu e por
tudo isto e vocês nem sabem o que
encontrei não vou dizer mourão seus
curiosos ok vamos lá continuar pessoal
agora celebrou ou estudaram um beco sem
saída para o futebol vai processar e
condenar que eu saí eu já tô sentindo o
cheiro da canela sabia que o cheiro
demônio porque o cheiro do boneco não e
gengibre e outra coisa é jean ao fuzilar
não é o cinema não é esse
eu vou jogar e buscam opel esquecem do
mundo chamas chegam a floro acho que é
isso
teixeira foi dura porque eu vou fazer a
minha vida porque eu tô jogar esta coisa
nos entrarmos no prison break vai
perceber que o careca
o senhor não pega o que aconteceu à
porta o que é isso isto é esqueço isso
vamos lá entrar
caíque tem mais balas hoje mas chumbado
to cannes que tem um choque ainda mais
de um papel só temos dois pessoal
estamos mais oculta chave meu deus só os
dois chuveiros já posso vender as minhas
chaves no ferro velho e ganhar baixem e
morreu
meu deus mais um armário ufu
apanhei espada do dom quixote já posso
matar as meninas mais rápidos londrina
anunciou o topo será que todo o mato o
supostamente já tenho uma chaminé duas
chaves a e por que eu não quisesse esta
parte né
acho que é que o caipira pretensão
pessoal fala num colóquio tradição é
tradição
faltam duas páginas ainda não encontrei
o olhar de uma escada
olha só vos filha scalioni o teu olho eu
mesmo um ateu fraca
a olho nu kre os cada hora de almoço em
londrina ano nosso ídolo woody à porter
uma pistola o já tem shopping sul
caçador agora meu deus não ter mar del
plata facas foram aí quem encomendar 80
armário de mim tirou op o enterro gemma
reclama sem colchão é mais pra [ __ ]
eu não percebo esta arquitetura e não
percebo londrina anda kaupa ele agora o
país já tem uma pistola a sério a outra
página já tem 13
falta um certo não perde com cinco olha
mais portas
dora dorme logo a dona do clube que é o
botafogo estou falando russo come já
algo assim o caracter mora vai morrer um
armário virado ao contrário daqui o
bagunça ativos confusa a um embrulho que
foi calma sem espada do workshop eu
percebo que eu vou fazer
nesta página já tem 14 a jovem ela já
vem ela já vem ela já o caxias parada do
dom quixote ordem no que vê lo já morreu
há qualquer coisa neste quarto eu tô sem
que eu estou sentindo aqui nominadas uma
banheira em fumo já da mills vocês
tomarem banho aqui vocês pegam tenta
cuidado nunca para banho em banheiro em
fujairah da olha aí a sua xi the fugees
não dá problema amanhã campeonato alemão
contra a caixa onde eu sou o cara dela
ou bem gostosa gostosa sim foi lindo o
episódio é preciso ir ao médico em
londrina
olha a peça o corcunda atrás das costas
com ingrid
eu tinha uma placa lá atrás tá bom é que
já tem cinco faltam 13 faltam três
pessoal esta última porta do corredor
pessoal por parte de você e quem é que
vai pôr ciro voz o gosto de quem 2 não
esteja com grêmio country chique não é
não apoiar nenhuma que lembro que o hu
tem um frango está aqui foco de trabalho
após um clique uma página
outro aulas na estante de madeira lá
para lá
era lá que este prémio é muito estranha
ai se não fosse o youtube era um
desenvolvedor de videojogos deste igual
este mesmo olha só o que eu descobri
partir porém de olho no que viu já
pararam também tudo o armário tem fugem
mil mton moro no armário faz muito
barulho a essa porto olha não abrir o
shopping de dóris changeywo que vai de
copa
o cae tem que encontrar um pé de cabra
dora no clube e lembrou que nunca
percebeu já está tudo fechado aqui
jorge onde é que será que está um pé de
cabra
uol o que é isto um pé de cabra não
estava nada à espera de encontrar esta
que não tava botafogo escondido ao
pessoal as estações não encontrava eu
tenho certeza só não sei não sei ok
agora é esse trabalho que tem que abrir
o brazil coletes e já tem seis
faltam duas páginas pessoal todo seu já
no top ser este o governo encontrou xavi
no encontro [ __ ] nenhuma
o lactec sete páginas já apanhei outra
falta mais uma
o tac oito páginas já meu cultive quebec
procura ao pis fundo gurupi to nato em
que o mesmo se diga que eu saí eu acho
que a minha espada
andré morreu olho sol
o namorado dela no seu entender que quer
um cisco brasil [ __ ] muito barulho de
morrer
a casa parabéns agora tu sabes que as
londrina pode ser morta sem dizer deve o
mesmo para o seu pai então é isso só
vamos ficar porque esticar
espero que vocês tenham gostado quanto
como falar em favorito como é mais jogos
como este
o boletim é um jogo bom é isso fiel e
meia até a próxima
a amm